Stolen,
same thing,
Stalin the great father,
right wise man at the helm of the ship
of the state.
This is after the wall came down,
some old man kissing a,
a gilded statue,
Stalin before it's going to be before
it's going to be torn down.
There he is with happy children and not
the children that his policies starve to
death as you,
as you might.
Well imagine.
There is in his military uniform sitting
on what's all,
for all intents and purposes,
a throne.
And this is,
this is really an uncanny one.
It's very positive,
right?
That's Hitler is or still in his head of
state.
He's in this hellish Mendola of fire.
Perfect with God the father at his head.
That's Lennon.
You know who people still,
who people still revere.
Um,
you may know and perhaps you don't,
that I was nominated to be rector of the
University of Glasgow.
And so,
which is an honorary position.
And today,
yesterday the different candidates put
up their manifestos in the student
newspaper,
put them up and then wrote analysis of
the manifestos which were biased.
And there were appallingly biased in one
sided.
And I wrote and told them that they
said,
well,
we have a perfect right to our political
opinion.
And I thought,
yeah,
well for sure,
but you know,
you are journalists after all and maybe
you could be just trying to tell what's
happening.
It's like,
no,
there's none of that.
And they said that one of the candidates
that they,
uh,
that they clearly recommended who seems
to be a person who's perfectly heroic in
his own right.
I mean he's taken on very many difficult
legal cases and,
and worked for the oppressed and
downtrodden who clearly exist.
Um,
it was either him or another candidate
doesn't really matter that they
described as bolshy and an outspoken
Bolshie meaning Bolshevik,
like,
it's like,
well,
you know,
he's appropriately Bolshie.
It's like,
it's no different than saying,
well,
he's appropriately not see.
Like,
like what the hell is that?
I mean there were 50 million people that
were killed in the Soviet Union by the
bowl.
She's and maybe twice that many in,
in China that,
that says nothing about Cambodia and all
the other places there were radical left
blood bass.
You think it's cute to call someone
Bolshie Jesus appalling.
It's appalling.
It's not some fashionable thing that you
do.
It's participation in some of the
deepest intellectual morasses of evil
that human beings have ever managed to
create,
and yet it's fashionable.
It shows you what,
what the universities are worth.
Well,
there's the downside of Stella.
Yeah.
Stella,
in his hangman,
that sort of cartoon would've gotten you
killed in the Soviet Union.
There are Stellan as st himself in a
stained glass representation.
There's a statue of Stella and covered
with red paint for the blood after the
wall came down there Stellan as what?
It's very much like Medina's Satan,
right?
You look at that and it's exactly the
same.
Marketable idea.
There's the Americans going.
It had a cap in hand,
get a little large.
Yes.
From Papa Stellan.
That's a painting of the Communists,
forcibly collectivizing,
the productive farmers in the Soviet
Union in the early 19 twenties.
The kulaks right.
Everything from whom they stole and rape
them and murdered them and ship them off
to Siberia and killed them and wiped out
the productive farmers of the Soviet
Union and then starved 6 million
Ukrainians to death.
And there is some poor kid in the 19
thirties who's ribs are showing,
you know,
taking a bath in this part with his eyes
wide.
And you know,
he's one of the fortunate ones because
he's still alive.
It's like bull sheet.
Yeah.
Cute.
Pretty Fun.
Fashionable,
lovely.